good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can build
your courage rule number five is our
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and
also as people are talking if someone
says something that really resonates
with you you know the drill
leave it down accounts below put your
quotes around that so other people can
be inspired as well enjoy here's the
stats from from your show and it says
the richest 85 people on this planet
have as much money as the poorest 3.5
billion yeah right on the planet however
sex it's not far off - in America no it
isn't far off in America but we still
and we still here don't abandon the idea
that it isn't finite it isn't finite if
you were born where we born me yeah
better is Louisiana better you know
Hospital there you know Louisiana I was
born in Memphis Tennessee
I had a long haul from where I came from
to here but here we are right so proof
is in the proof of the pudding is in
eating and may we sit the dining table
but it's hard to when you say that to
some people because they say oh there
you go with a pull yourself up by the
bootstraps thing and you know you're
just being respectable not everybody can
do that
look everybody can
I thought it doesn't courage courage is
the key to life itself
a lot of people who are born in
situation Misurata
I'll never get out of this so they won't
I say to people say well I would like to
have done so and so and so so you could
have done it so but I couldn't get out
of here man the bus runs every day
you're exactly right now you're sit
there if there if you can conceive it in
your mind if you can think of it you can
go that's a human condition and we can
imagine if we can do it right and I
think that the condition of each
individual human ten years from now
you're going to arrive the questions
where if you don't do something today
you're going to show up somewhere so
what happens is when you go through the
natural disappointments and frustrations
when things don't work out the way you
expected when people betray you or
disappoint you or hurt you what happens
is all cynicism is all skepticism is is
a protective device that says I don't
wanna get my hopes up because I don't
want to feel that drop of disappointment
I want to feel the loss I don't want to
feel the hurt so people tell me I'm
cynical I'm pessimistic I look up and
say listen let's be honest you're
gutless it doesn't take any any courage
to think things don't work and they're
wrong and they're terrible and never fix
because you'll never be disappointed cuz
you'll never take any action so it won't
change its self-fulfilling but it takes
guts to say I'm going to believe in
something and try it even though I might
fail the first fourth tenth time I'm
going to keep going and I believe that
most human beings that they put yourself
on the line they would uncover who they
really are but most of us are so afraid
of failing or not looking good or or
losing out that we just never discover
who we are what I think we have in
common is we're willing to step into the
uncertainty all passion is found in the
realm of uncertainty and yet human
beings are pulled to certainly because
we you know we don't want to deal with
our fears freedom liberation is we break
through the fears all of my brethren out
there all my brothers and sisters
watching who are entrepreneurs or or
considering being entrepreneurs
you are what I made for I'm not I go 18
companies 12 actively managed five
billion in save who told you 1200 plays
and blows my mind I have no business
background but I have this passion that
says I must do more for others than
anybody else and I'll never stop growing
and I'll never stop changing I'll never
stop improving and I feel alive by doing
that as opposed to let me do the same
thing every day because I'm good at it
and let me continue to do that hopefully
my life is really good that'll make you
feel you know feel numb if not depressed
you're frustrated overwhelmed which is
where most human beings lives develop
the courage courage is not the absence
of fear courage is the willingness to
act in spite of the fear I had a fear of
speaking because I don't have a college
education and a fear of becoming an
entrepreneur because I never had an
experience of any background in business
I had a fear of so many things I was
living a fear driven life as you look at
yourself and look at your goals develop
the courage to go after your goals to
live your dreams and not your fears and
understand and here's something that's
very important that anything that's
worth doing is worth doing badly I don't
want to make any mistakes hey anything
is worth doing at all it's worth doing
badly why because it's worth doing right
if you know how to do it but if you
don't know how to do it
it's worth doing badly until you get it
right just like I'll mess it up right
now but you forgive me won't you
of course you will so as you look at
yourself anything that's worth doing
it's worth doing badly until you get it
right and as you make mistakes you learn
from your mistakes you come back again
and again and again they ask Benjamin
Franklin Noah was Thomas Edison Thomas
Edison is Sir Thomas Edison how did you
continue to get to learn how to develop
the light love in spite of the fact that
you had 10,000 billions and eat that he
didn't have 10,000 billions you said he
had 10,000 waves that did not work Wow
think about that today anything that
you're going through right now
if you want to take a big scary leap and
you want to start a new career or
perhaps start a business anything that
you might consider a failure is really
just a necessary step on your journey
to success so no matter what you're
facing right now no matter what's
getting you so scared there's only one
question that you need to ask and answer
to find the courage to make that big
leap and the question is this what's the
worst thing that can happen so not just
by saying yes but what's the worst thing
that could happen if you said no so for
example a few years ago I asked my
really dear friend Laura to come speak
at one of our live events now this was a
big opportunity for her but I know it
was kind of stressful and I said you
know what this is big so take a few days
think about it because once you say yes
you're going to be locked in so first
she had to ask herself well what's the
worst thing that could happen if I said
yes so for her it was the stress it was
wishing that she never committed which
she wished she never committed but it
was also this fear that she was going to
completely freeze up on stage that she
was going to mess up horribly and
completely ruin her reputation which she
did not now on the flip side she had to
ask yourself what's the worst thing that
could happen if she said no so you got
to get that Laura really wanted to grow
her business and her brand and if she
said no to this opportunity she'd have
to face herself in the mirror every
single day and say nice going bonehead
you had the perfect opportunity to grow
your business and you turned it down so
now it's your turn I want you to ask
yourself what's the worst possible thing
that could happen if you said yes and
you'd fail miserably so don't just think
about this loosely I want you to get
really specific and tease out every
single scenario that could possibly go
wrong and how you deal with it if it did
what most of us discover is that no
matter what the worst case scenario is
we can actually handle it but don't
forget you got to go on the flip side
too and ask yourself what's the worst
thing that can happen if you decide to
do nothing and keep your life exactly as
it is
are your regrets going to start to pile
up like pancakes you're going to turn
into some miserable self-loathing
sad-sack I really want you to tease this
one out and get all the scenarios on the
table and then take a look what do you
got
the worst of the worst going for it or
not going for it
I believe the master emotion of all life
is enthusiasm if you're enthusiastic
about something you're engaged with it
if you're enthusiastic about something
you feel energized for it if you're
enthusiastic about something you look
forward to waking up tomorrow and go and
forth so prime that feeling every day
the way that I do that is every morning
in the shower when I'm getting ready I
think what could I be excited about for
today what could I have enthusiasm flow
today and if I can't come up with
anything off the top of my head or by
looking at my schedule I create it I
said okay what could I do today that
would be fun and make me look forward to
the day maybe prank a friend
maybe it's do something good for
somebody maybe it's something I'm going
to do that I just really enjoyed it
won't be I won't spend a lot of time
during the day by me to give myself 30
minutes doing a passion small little
project I'm interested in whatever it is
prime enthusiasts because if you have
that feeling of enthusiasm that's what's
going to keep you passionate over long
term and please listen you need to prime
your enthusiasms every day see a lot of
people are very passionate people but
they're not living passionately because
every day they're not engaging with what
they want you know they set the big goal
at New Year's with in February and April
rolls around they forgotten about it but
the reason they were so excited in
January that the New Year why is
everyone excited they're priming
enthusiasm they're looking at their
goals they're having an emotional
connection and commitment to that and
that excites them for the year so what
you need to do is look at your goals
every day what you need to do is every
day write the things down and important
to it get excited about doing that
implementing experiencing it and go for
it
it makes my heart my friends like live
for Friday night like they know they get
there we like Monday mornings the worst
it's just such a huge percentage of
one's life I can't wrap my head around
with the internet this is not your
grandpappy's life we have the internet
you can make happen you can build
businesses or side hustles I just don't
understand why people relegate into
losing mentality and just thinking they
can't you can't because you want to be
on the bowling team or softball and play
video games that's why you can't there's
plenty of time get [ __ ] done the level
of complaining is unacceptable look what
if I told you this was the last Monday
morning of your life
what if I go do you digest week would
you complain about your crap job or that
test you don't want to think I doubt it
you'll go much higher level thinking
well that's really what it takes it
takes understanding that if you're not
hung right now if you're begrudging what
you're about to do is here if you're not
looking forward please recognize the
world we're living in we're living in a
world where so much more opportunity
this internet thing created way more
opportunity for all of us way more I
mean really let him be alive but your
mom and dad could have had sex like
three years later and you weren't even
exist and you're complaining you could
have ended up being a buck a three I
just don't get to mentality being head
down sad on a Monday morning I'm going
to make Monday morning my [ __ ] I'm
going to make you Saturday Monday
morning that's what I want to do every
morning and that's what I want from you
please take a step back and think about
how awesome it actually is and then
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way because you
are lucky enough to be born during this
tear up so my take on building courage
is I think it's like a muscle I think
it's something that you need to develop
and constantly push and train yourself
to get stronger and stronger and
stronger there will be periods every
single day that you have the opportunity
to build your courage muscle and what
usually happens for most people is they
have this opportunity in front of them
that is scary that they've never done
before that they're afraid of and
they'll justify it with the practical
reason you tell yourself you can't do
because of all this and it'll make total
sense to you and you just shrink down
you
silly play the smaller game the weak
your game instead of being bold and
believing in yourself and trying to go
for and take that action and so how do
you go from being afraid and being
scared to actually having the courage to
do it here's what I found really helps
it's really helped for me multiple times
and I think it can help you the first
part is the awareness so many people
just play small by default they don't
even realize that they're playing small
it's just so ingrained in you that it
just happens constantly every day you
talk yourself down from things every
single day and it makes perfect logical
sense the reasons why you say you can't
do something are rational they make
sense until you constantly do it but
when you catch yourself it's usually not
the moment it's like the next day or the
next week you catch yourself to say you
know what yesterday I should have done
that I should have said yes I was just
too afraid why didn't I say yes that
self-awareness that's the start that is
the start if you can realize it don't
don't worry about it being a day later
or two days later a week later if you
can realize at any point that you played
small the other day that's the starting
point because the next time it happens
you want to catch it again it's going to
get a little closer instead of it being
the next day it'll be a couple hours
next time it happens you'll get a little
bit closer next time it happens it'll be
as you're leaving that meeting you
realize almost instantly that I did it
again I did it again I'm playing small
I'm justifying these things when I
shouldn't be I should better myself I
need to believe in myself and then the
magical moment happens the magical
moment happens when you have the
opportunity sitting immediately in front
of you and you have the decision to make
you catch it in the moment instead of
the next day or the next week you catch
it as it's happening where somebody asks
you the question to say do you want to
do this and in your head you're thinking
about all the reasons why you can't and
you pet yourself say this is it this is
what always happens I'm about to play
small again and then developing the
courage to say I'm going to do it I'm
going to try I'm going to say yes and
what really helped me is just thinking
that I am tired of living with regrets
once you can catch it once you have the
self-awareness to catch that you're
playing small consistently I was tired
of living with the regret of constantly
playing smaller than I should and when
you're in that moment and you have to
make that decision and you're afraid
it's okay to be afraid it's not be
fearless you're going to be afraid it's
feeling the fear doing it anyway because
you don't want to live in regret for the
rest of your life looking back on this
moment in saying I played small again
and so that has really really really
helped me a lot it's helped me develop
the courage muscle to the point now
where whenever I'm afraid of something
whenever I'm worried about somebody
else's opinion whenever I feel like
maybe I can't do that then I have to
force myself to go out and do it if
there's a real reason not to do it right
like I'm not interested in it I don't
have the passion for that I don't
actually care about that then I won't go
and do it but if I have a passion for it
and then the only reason that I'm not
doing it because I'm afraid then I force
myself to go out and do it every time
you do that you build your courage
muscle up every time you're afraid you
want a small one small little
interaction talking to that girl on the
street having that difficult
conversation with your partner employee
your customer every time you think of
something that you need to do and you're
afraid to do it and then you do it you
build your courage muscle up every
single time you get stronger and
stronger and stronger and what I want
you to develop the habit this is so
important I want you to develop the
habit of whenever something difficult
comes up you resolve it you jump into it
you address it instead of shrinking down
because if shrinking down is all the way
up here and addressing it's all the way
down here I want you to start to switch
this I want you to switch it where now
every time there's something major some
big problem something you're afraid of
something that you might regret you're
going to attack it every single time and
you're no longer going to accept playing
small with your business and with your
life so thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because
Wambach philosophy asked me to so
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of believe life
leave it in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do I'd also love to know
what did you take from this video what
was your favorite clip what was the
favorite story what are you going to
immediately apply to your life
your business so such an important topic
if you guys can be more courageous in
what you're doing
it will have such a dramatic impact on
your life and the people around you so
what did you learn and what are you
going to apply immediately to your
business in your life leave a down
comments below I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Peter ARCA Peter
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book dear one word and taking that
picture I love it I hope you enjoy the
read main and I really appreciate the
support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
loved have an amazing day and I'll see
you soon